there was a viewer of this channel who
sent in a handful of viral pro-abortion
tick-tocks from a very very confused
young woman and she asked if i would
refute the arguments or the pseudo
arguments that this chickie was making
so we did the first video
last time we're gonna take on the second
video right now by the time that you
made your coffee this morning
thousands of little babies had already
been taken from the mother's womb
the audacity of some men on this app to
make bullsh emotional videos like the
one you just saw
judging women for a choice
this reminds me of a video i think it
was from fox news with gavin mcginnis
and some feminist woman and
gavin was being typically provocative
and he was making some joke which was
only half a joke about how women should
raise their children and how that's more
fulfilling than being a middle manager
at some widget factory and
he said women are more emotional and the
woman on the panel says how dare you
call me emotional now i would never be
yeah look you're miserable you would be
so much happier with kids around you
tonight so i think you're
i think you're kind of proving the point
here okay go on judging women for a
choice that they will never personally
have to face is ludicrous and brandon
seems like you need a little
enlightenment buddy so let's [ __ ] go
did you know that every 10 seconds a
report of child abuse is made and how do
you think your stance of forcing
children into the world under
circumstances in which they are unwanted
affects that child positive what she's
saying you hear this argument from
pro-abortion people a lot is some
children are not wanted which is why
their parents kill them so it's better
for the child to be killed than to be
unwanted so if that's true then you must
support a policy of killing kids in
orphanages by killing kids in the foster
care system because they're not wanted
by their parents they're not wanted by
their families that's why they're wards
of the state
no no child is actually totally unwanted
one we want them to live and they're
wanted by god it is
just for them to be able to live
but they're not by the by this woman's
standard they're not wanted and so okay
if that's true then kill all the kids in
the orphanages now she would never come
out and say that take it even further
what what is at the heart of this
argument is that death is better than
suffering these kids they're going to
suffer if you're in the foster care
system if you're unwell if you're abused
by a parent or something you you are
going to suffer and death is better than
suffering
what's the end of that everybody suffers
yes exactly every single person suffers
that is part of this life this is a
fallen world the only thing i can
promise you i'll promise you two things
you will suffer and you will die
okay does that mean you just gotta call
it in throw in the towel we all ought to
kill ourselves no this woman doesn't
think that she obviously isn't killing
herself she isn't openly advocating
though she is implicitly advocating for
killing
orphans suffering actually is not not a
cause to throw in the towel or kill
somebody or give up suffering actually
can be edifying we all know that it is
in our deepest struggles and the most
difficult things we we wrestle with very
often that we grow the most that we
learn the most that we gain the most
wisdom that we mature the most that's
right foster children hard work builds
character suffering is in a sense a kind
of neutral
fact of life
you can either react to it in a
destructive way like this woman is or
you can react to it in an edifying way
in a way of
humility and courage and patience
and temperance in a virtuous way all
right go on and i know they can just be
adopted tell that to the four hundred
thousand children of the foster care
system
she's saying because they're kids in
foster care obviously there are many
more kids that would be put up for
adoption than parents who want to adopt
them that's not true it's actually the
opposite is true there are an estimated
36 couples in this country who are
trying to adopt for every one baby every
one newborn put up for adoption the kids
in the foster care system by and large
were brought there when they were older
after they had grown up in a difficult
family situation maybe their parents
lost custody maybe maybe a parent died
and there was no family around then they
end up in the foster care system and
it's true there is a dearth of couples
who want to adopt a troubled 15 year old
it's a sad fact of life not my mother
todd but there is no shortage of couples
who want to adopt newborn babies and
when we're talking about abortion we're
talking about people who will either
will become newborn babies or will be
killed before they can be born and there
are 36 couples trying to adopt every
single one of those babies who either
will be put up for adoption or will be
killed yes we all know that amazon gift
cards are fast and easy but why not go
for something a little more meaningful
this year with dwell you can do just
that dwell is an audio app that makes it
fun and easy to get into the bible
whether you've read every verse or are
looking to read it for the first time
dwell makes it easy to discover or
rediscover the bible's timeless wisdom
your family and friends will love this
scripture listening app especially if
they're not big into reading right now
for all of my listeners dwell is
offering 50 off gift card purchases that
is 55-0
percent off just go to dwell app dot io
slash knowles canada wlas get a dwell
gift card for a friend or family member
for fifty five zero percent off now
all gift cards can be emailed to their
recipients so you can knock out your
holiday shopping right this free second
don't battle the parking lot or the
throng of people at your neighborhood
mall
actually just give people the gift of
the word of god scripture itself go to
dwell app dot io slash knowles canon
wles to get a gift card for a family
member or friend for 50 off give the
gift of the bible this year with a dwell
gift card and did you know that for
every one woman who loses her life to
pregnancy and childbirth another 20
experience serious injury infection and
disability in relation to pregnancy and
labor and you expect women to be forced
to endure that kind of risk and did you
know that every one in six children in
america experience food insecurity
meaning let's take a pause one is
skeptical of these sorts of statistics
that one of the biggest problems
plaguing the united states and
specifically the poor in the united
states is obesity not starvation but
obesity
but we can make a video about
food insecurity and
the supply chain some other time what
she's saying here is that women
sometimes suffer complications from
pregnancy that's obviously true it's
exaggerated but that's obviously true
but what's the alternative the
alternative is killing
your kid and she's setting up this false
idea that the choices between
choosing to have the child or not making
the choice not to have the child but you
already have the child the child already
exists so the question is are you going
to kill the child and by the way women
suffer huge complications from abortion
too women die from abortions i mean that
was what the kermit gosnell case was
about the greatest mass murderer in
american history was an abortionist
named kermit gosnell taking that aside
for a moment let's say even just
focusing on birth some women will suffer
complications okay well the alternative
is killing your baby so which is worse
this is a fallen world take a pic what's
worse kill your kid and still very
likely suffer complications and injury
or
have your kid and have a beautiful baby
and maybe risk suffering a little bit
well that's what kids do we sacrifice
for our kids that's called being a
parent so while you sit there with your
coffee and superiority complex one in
six children don't know if they're gonna
have breakfast and how do you think your
stance of forcing children into a world
in which they may not be able to be
cared for pause
they're already in the world they're
already in the world you actually got to
flip what she's saying on its head the
kids are already in the world
so now you you have a choice
young lady you can either force kids out
of the world by grinding them up through
abortion is it a real grind or is it
some kind of a metaphor or you can take
care of them or try to reform the foster
care system or give charity or adopt or
all of which the pro-life people do at a
huge rate a very high rate and far more
obviously than people who are on the
other side of that question all right
let's wrap it up and did you know that
the united nations has designated forced
pregnancy as a crime against humanity
and your bio says that you're a jesus
lover or a lover of jesus and spoiler
alert jesus would not be on your side on
this one
well no that's not true the catholic
church which you know was the only
church in until the well first the
schism of the 11th century and then the
protestant revolution of the 16th
century but actually all of the churches
agreed on this question even into
modernity and the one church that there
was the one christian church that there
was going back all the way to antiquity
all the way back to the first century in
the year of our lord
prohibited abortion going back to the
ddokay going back to the earliest
documents we have from the nation
christian church we know
that the church prohibited
abortion so she's wrong obviously on the
on the christianity point here in terms
of forced pregnancy you know
not killing babies is a crime against
humanity is her argument now without
delving too much into the united nations
obviously this this isn't true the
united nations also says a child has the
right to his mother and father but
if your definition of a crime against
humanity
involves not killing humans if your
definition of a human right is killing
the most vulnerable humans your
conception of human rights is probably a
little bit off it doesn't make any sense
okay we've got one more video that
maddie the illustrious viewer of this
show has sent in of these crazy
pro-abortion arguments that we are going
to knock down we don't have time to do
it now so we'll be doing it next time
please send in any videos that you would
like me to destroy with facts and logic
more than happy to take a look at those
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you